[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه ستون ساعه
الايقاع السريع والمختلف والمعلومه
المباشره الوافيه وفيها الكثير البدايه من
العناوين
هجوم واوكرانيا المضاده رسميا لم يبدا لكن
دبابات النيتو المحترقه دليل
اتفاق جديد في السودان لوقت اطلاق النار
الالتزام به يمنع مجاعه وشيكا
وفي ملفات الساعه 60
حرب المياه بين ايران وافغانستان قد تمتد
لما هو ابعد قنبله موقوته لاسيا الوسطى
الذكاء الاصطناعي ان عاش سوق التكنولوجيا
المتنحه لكن خطره في الارهاب قد يغطي على
ميزاته
بعد الهجمات التي شهدها العمق الروسي جاءت
دور على اقليمي بالقروده ليتحمل اثقل
الحرب اوكرانيا نجاحات في نقل المنطقه
الرماديه التي تفصل الحدود الروسيه وخركيز
الى الداخل الروسي لكن موسكو فعلت كل ما
بوسعها من اجل عدم الانجرار وراء فتح جبهه
جديده قد تكون وهميه استراتيجيه التقارير
الروسيه تؤكد ذلك وكما كان متوقعا انطلق
الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاد بعد اشهر من
الانتظار وان كانت اوكرانيا تنفيه بشكل
رسمي المفاجاه كانت في تفاصيل الخطه
الاوكرانيه وما سبقها من احدا
صوتك خلال الايام القليله الماضيه قام
النظام الاوكراني ببدء هجومه الموعود الذي
روج له طويلا لقد قاموا بالهجوم على محاور
عديده على الجبهه ولقد سخروا لتحقيق هدفهم
كميه كبيره من المعدات والقوات
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تصرفت وكانها توقعت
تفاصيل الهجوم الاوكرانيه المضاد والذي لن
يخرج بحسبها من جنوب دونيا فاوكرانيا لن
تتخلى ببساطه عن فكره فصل خرسون عن بقيه
دومباس ان كانت تريد فعلا استرجاع استرجاع
شبه جزيره القرم ايام قبل الهجوم تعرضت
المناطق الحدوديه جنوب مقاطعه الى قصفا
مكثف وصل الى ما معدله 850 قذيفه مدفعيه
يوميا معدل لم تشهده الحرب من قبل وما
تحصده روسيا الان في بلغرود هو نتيجه
لقرار سابق ضم روسيا لمناطق اوكرانيا لم
يشمل مقاطعه خركيب وهو ما عجل بالانسحاب
من مناطق واسعه بهدف تقليل امتداد الجبهه
لكن الامور تغيرت عندما بدا الجيش الروسي
في بناء التحصينات وجد نفسه مضطرا
لتشييدها في العمق الروسي تجنبا
المدفعيه الاوكرانيه والتي يصل مداها الى
40 كيلومترا ومع اقتراب الهجوم تحول
الاستفزاز الى مناوشات ثم قصف متواصل وفر
تغطيه لعناصر تخريبيه متسلله لتتحول اراد
الروسيه الى منطقه رماديه
[موسيقى]
وصفه مقاطعه لا يحمل اهميه
عملياتيه لكن من الواضح انك وافقه مصادر
روسيه التاسعه لتشتيت موسكو واستدراج
قواتها نحو جبهه جديده بعيدا عن موقع
الهجوم الحقيقي اوكرانيا هاجمت في خمسه
محاور اقحمت دبابات اليوبارد ومدرعات عشره
الفرنسيه لاول مره وهنا دليل اخر على
انطلاق الهجوم المضاد والوجهه كانت اجلدار
الواقعه بين جبهتي
منطقه تعتبرها اوكرانيا اضعف بين الاضعف
بين الدفاعات الروسيه لكن الهجوم لم يحدث
كما كان متوقعا جاء الدور على اوكرانيا
لارتكاب اخطاء روسيا قوافل الدبابات
الغربيه وقعت فخا في يد المروحيات
الهجوميه الروسيه كما نشاهد مشاهدينا
خطا اوكراني اخر نقل المدفعيات نحو
بالقرود افقد كييف القدره على توفير تغطيه
كافيه لسلاح المدفعيه قبل الهجوم نتائج
اليوم الاول كانت تكرارا لبغموت على نطاق
واسع
[موسيقى]
تاخر الهجوم المضاد كثيرا ولكياب اسبابها
ربما اولا الغرب تردد في ارسال الاسلحه
الثقيله والثانيا
اصر على الصمود فيها لتخسر كياب الكثير من
الوقت القوات الروسيه حصلت على الوقت
اللازم لبناء دفاعات موثوقه لكن حديقه
واحده اعادت توزيع الاوراق في جبهه كانت
منسيه تفجير سد نوفا واين في خرسون
المدينه التي شهدت ما يعرف بالانسحاب
اللغز للقوات الروسيه تراجعت قبل الشتاء
الماضي لتتحصنه وراء نهر دنيبر وموسكو
تحججت وقتها بتدمير جسري انطونوبسكي شريان
الحياه الوحيد بين خرسون وبقيه المقاطعه
الخطوه سمحت بانقاذ عشرين الف جندي الروسي
كانوا معزولين في الجبهه الاخرى ولا مجال
لامدادهم لكن هذه كانت روايه واحده للقصه
روايه اخرى جاءت على اللس
لقد قمت باعلام شركائنا الاوروبيين اليوم
خلال اجتماع المجلس الاوروبي بخصوص الهجوم
الروسي المقبل
تستعد روسيا لتدمير سد نوفا ومحطته
الكهرومائيه حسب المعلومات المتوفره لدينا
ويجب على كل العالم ان يعمل بكل قوه من
اجل منع حدوث هذا الهجوم الارهابي الروسي
بينما الكثير من الدلائل هناك تتحدث عن
بدئه حيث شنت اوكرانيا ضربات صاروخيه
ومدفعيه وبالمسيرات والعبوات الناسفه طالت
عده مناطق في غرب روسيا ودون باس بالاضافه
لهجمات بريه على عدد من النقاط الحدوديه
اما هنا فاعلنت وزاره دفاع موسكو عن بدء
تعزيز طال انتظاره لقوتها العسكريه مع
نهايه هذا العام يتمثل بجيش بري واخر جوي
وفيلق عسكريا بالاضافه الى قوه ازوف
البحريه وخمس فرق وسته وعشرين لواء كما
يدور الحديث عن انشاء منطقتين ع في كل من
موسكو
رئيس الاوكراني
روسيا بمحاوله تفجير سد نوفا قليله قبل
انسحابها من مدينه خرسون وقتها قائد
القوات الروسيه في اوكرانيا
السابقين الامر ورد التهمه لاوكرانيا
اشاره الى ان محطه نوفا تعرضت للقصف من
قبل كييف مرات عده بصواريخ
وبحسب سيرابكين كان الهدف اغراق مناطق
السيطره الروسيه واجبارها على مغادره غرب
خرسون وهو ما سيسمح للجيش الاوكراني من
عبور نهر النيفر دون قتال روسيا سحبت
بعدها بايام من غرب نهر النيفر سد النوفا
لم يدمر لكنه تعرض للاستهداف مرات كثيره
ولم تنقصه الا الضربه الاخيره التي افاضت
مياهها
[موسيقى]
سنضع الابعاد العسكريه جانبا وهناك كارثه
انسانيه وباياره فقط تدمير خزان نوفا
والسبب 18 كيلومترا مكعبا من المياه دمرت
معها كل ما يوجد على ضفاف نهر دنيبر الجهه
الواقعه تحت السيطره الروسيه كانت الاكثر
تاثرا اضافه الى انسحاب الجيشين اضطره
سكان اربعين بلده النزوح نحو مناطق اكثر
امانا جهود الجيشين ذهبت هباء بعد ان جرفت
المياه الالغام وهدمت الخنادق والتحصينات
الحصار المياه وجفاف الاوحال بعد اسابيع
سيعيد الجبهه الى نقطه الصفر
رغم ذلك موسكو وكيف تبادلتها الاتهامات
بخصوص المسؤوله عن تفجير سد نوفا والسبب
هو تضارب المعلومات حول الطريقه التي
استهدف بها السد الروايه الروسيات تتحدث
عن صاروخي ستورب شادو البريطاني استهدف
جدار السد بشكل مباشر مما تسبب في دمار
جزء هام كان كافيا لتسرب المياه لكن السد
عباره عن كتله اسمنتيه متماسكه ولا يستطيع
صاروخ واحد مهما كانت قوته تدمير السد
والتسبب في ضرر مماثل وهنا قدمت اوكرانيا
روايتها البديله القوات الروسيه وخوفا من
تقدم اوكرانيا عبر نهر دنيبر قامت بوضع
متفجرات والغام في اماكن محدده لضمان
العمليه وهنا نجحت موسكو في ربح هدنه قد
تمتد لاسابيع في جبهه خرسون لكن جهات
محايده اعطت روايه اخرى اكثر واقعيه
يعاني اصلا من تسريب المياه بسبب تعرضه
للاستهداف مرات عند اما الضربه فقد اجهزت
على هيكله الذي لم يصمد امام قوه دفع
المياه لكن بغض النظر عن المسؤول التفجير
حدث بالفعل الاخطر فيه الكارثه البيئيه
المرتقبه الضربه لم تدمر السده وحده بل
ايضا محطه توليد الطاقه المرافقه امر تسبب
في تسرب 150 طنا من النفط الى النهر ضربه
موجعه للزراعه خرسون بالطبع تمتد
تداعياتها للحياه البحريه في البحر الاسود
[موسيقى]
ومن القاهره ينضم الينا لواء سمير فرج
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا بك يبدو
ان الهجوم المضاد قد بدا بالفعل وايضا
بتصريحات الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين يؤكد ان
هذا الهجوم بدا بالفعل ولكن بعد طول
انتظار لهذا الهجوم بدا بدفعه ضعيفه وذلك
بحسب الاعلام الغربي هل اخطات اوكرانيا
والغرب معها في حساباتهم لهذا الهجوم ام
ان هذا جزء من الخطه
مساء الخير لحضرتك وكل الساده المشاهدين
احب اقول لحضرتك ان هو الهجوم اذا كان بدا
وليس الهجوم الرئيسي عشان نحلل العسكري
لهذا الموقف الهجوم المضاد الرئيسي بيبدا
بتجميع وحشد قوات رئيسيه بتشمل ثلاثه
للمهاجم ضد وعد للمدافع ما يحدث الان هو
حجم محدود فده بنسميه
اني باجي بهاجم على المواجهه بالكامل عشان
انقي اضعف قوات ومناطق اقدر اهاجم فيها
بعد كده بالقوه الرئيسيه بتاعتي وابدا
انفذ الهجوم فعشان كده بنقول دي المرحله
الاولى من الهجوم المضارع
الهجوم هذا ما تقصد
ايوه بالظبط يا فندم الدفاعيه
شاهدنا دبابات النيتو وهي تحترق
كبيره بالظبط
ما انا اقول لحضرتك ليه احنا في فتره
الشتاء اللي فاتت القوات الروسيه خدت 14
عشان تجهيز الدفاعات واحنا هنا في مصر
احنا بنتبع نفس الاسلوب بتاع الدفاع
الروسي والهجوم الروسي فعشان كده هم خدوا
وقت كبير جدا نظامه دفاعاتهم الخطوط
بتاعتهم خنادي المواصلات التحويليه مرابط
المدفعيه عشان كده احنا بنقول من اول يوم
انا الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني لن يكون سهلا
الحاجه التانيه ان يجب كان يجب ايضا على
الهجوم المضاد الاوكرانيا ان ينتظر الى ان
تصل على الاقل الاف 16 هل ينفذ هجمه مضاده
على دفعات قويه واستحكمات والاف 16 حتصل
بعد اربعه اشهر قادمه عشان كده احنا بنقول
هو ده تحضير ابتدائي للهجوم المضاد لحينما
تصل بقيه القوات لسه النهارده امريكا جو
بايدن
اوكرانيا اتنين مليار دولار ليه عشان
تدعيمه بالقوات الدفاع الجوي احنا عندنا
الشهر اللي فات روسيا نجحت في تدمير
بطاريه من الاربع بطاريات بتوع الباترول
اللي موجوده على كيف ورغم ان اوكرانيا نفت
انما
امريكا تاني يوم قالت ايوه ده حصل وبعتت
عناصر عشان نشوف ايه اللي حصل فالنهارده
عشان انفذ الهجوم المضاد لازم يكون عندي
سيطره جويه النهارده اوكرانيا ليست لديها
سيطره جويه على مصر العمليات
بالبقاء معنى رجاء سنعود الى الاستعدادات
الروسيه ولكن دعنا نتوقف مع هذا التصريح
للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين اليوم وتحدث
فيه عن الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني لكن كان
في حديثه اعتراف روسيا تعاني من نقص
الاسلحه الحديثه
يمكن التاكيد ان الهجوم الاوكرانيه قد بدا
ويشهد على ذلك استخدام الاحتياطي
الاستراتيجي القوات الاوكرانيه لم تحقق
اهدافها على اي من محاور العمليات
القتاليه خسائر هائله تكبدء الجيش
الاوكراني خلال هذه الايام بواقع ثلاثه
جنود مقابل جنديه الروسي من المعلوم ان
الخسائر خلال العمليات الهجوميه تكون
موجوده وهذا امر معتاد لكن في حالتنا هذه
فانها تتجاوز المؤشرات المعتاده لا نملك
ما يكفي من الاسلحه الحديثه بعد لكن
الصناعه العسكريه تتطور وستنجز جميع
المهام الموكوله لها
ان نعود الى ضيفنا لواء سمير فرج الله
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي يعني كما
ذكرت القوات الروسيه تحضرت جيدا ولكن الان
ياتي التصريح فلاديمير بوتين يقول هناك
نقص في الاسلحه والمعدات الحديثه اين يضع
هذا استراتيجيه وخطه روسيا لصد الهجوم
المضاد وايضا للخطوات القادمه في عمليتها
العسكريه في اوكرانيا
طبعا انا انا شفت هذا التصريح من ساعتين
لما صدر وهو بوتين بهذا الكلام بيبرر انه
رغم كل هذه الامكانيات لان هو النهارده
بيحارب ليس اوكرانيا فقط هو بيحارب
اوكرانيا وبقيت دول حلف الناتو لان طبعا
كل الاسلحه والمعدات الجديده بتيجي من دول
الناتو لدعم اوكرانيا في هذه المعركه
ولذلك هو طبعا بيكبر القوات بتاعته بيقول
ان رغم هذا الكلام ده كله احنا وهما بداوا
الهجوم المضاد لكن هو طبعا بيعترف لانه
عنده نقص كبير جدا في الذخيره عنده نقص
كبير جدا في الاسلحه المتطوره اللي
واخداها اوكرانيا من حلف الناتو ولكن طبعا
في هذا الامور بيقول ان المصانع الحربيه
الروسيه ستعمل بجد لانها تعوض ما تطلبه
للقوات على الجبهه واحنا ما ننساش ان قائد
فارنار وهو بيهاجم ضخمه كان بيقول انا
محتاج ذخيره انا عايز ولازم نبقى عارفين
ان مثل هذا النوع من القتال القتال في
المدن بيحتاج كميات كبيره جدا من الذخيره
طبعا اوكرانيا بتمون من كل دول حلف الناتو
انما روسيا ما عندهاش غير المصانع بتاعتها
عشان كده النهارده كان بوتين بيقول هذا
الكلام وان رغم كل الكلام ده محوش اي نجاح
واعتقد ان هو بيمهد لحاجه تانيه هتتم في
المستقبل القريب ان هو ياخد اسلحه من
مناطق اخرى هو فعلا محتاج اسلحه متطوره
ولكن وايضا ذخيره لان زي ما قلت اوكرانيا
بتاخد ذخيره من بقيه دوله حلف الناتو اما
روسيا معندهاش غير المصانع بتاعتها ورغم
ذلك انا بعتقد ان الهجوم المضاد الرئيسي
الاوكراني سيتاخر بعض الشيء اسمحي لي بس
بدقيقتين اقول حاجه ثانيه ان هو اقل
دقيقتين وقت طويل في اقل وفي عجاله رجاء
طيب هقول لك بسرعه ايوه هقول لك بسرعه ان
امريكا حصل فيها تسريب لوثائق السريه
الفشار اللي فات وقعد الوصايا كان فيها
تقديرات البنتاجون بتقول ايه ان اذا تم
هجوم اوكرانيا حاليا فلن يجع واذا نجح
هيتم نقول ايه بصوره متواضعه وهذا لن يكون
في صالح الاوكرانيين اذا دخلوا في اي
مفاوضات قادمه مع الروس نعم ايضا معهد
دراسات الحرب الامريكيه يتحدث عن ثغرات في
الهجوم المضاد اشكرك جزيل الشكر كنت معنا
من القاهره اللواء سمير فرج الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي شكرا لك
تمنونا في المئه من اليد العامله في
السودان في خطر في الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد ثمانيه اسابيع مرت على
بدء النزاع المسلح وما يزال السودان يعيش
في حلقه مفرغه قتال ثم مفاوضات تليها هدنه
مؤقته لا تنال ثقه الطرفين لتكسر من جديد
شوارع الخرطوم وبحري واندرمان تحولت الى
فتنه عسكريه وساحه قتال مع اصرار الطرفين
على تحقيق النصر لكن محاولات احلال السلام
لا تزال موجوده اليوم اعلنت الخارجيه
السعوديه توصل الطرفين لاتفاق لوقف اطلاق
النار لاربعه وعشرين ساعه يبدا صباح غدا
السبت ماذا ان لم يلتزم الطرفان نتيجه
ستكون تاجيل محددات جده
حققنا بعض النجاح لم يكن نجاحا كاملا لان
الاطراف لم يلتزموا التزاما كاملا ونستمر
في العمل لبحث السبل لرفع المعاناه عن
الشعب السوداني عن طريق الوصول الى
تفاهمات معينه مع الاطراف هناك بوادر
ايجابيه حتى اليوم في المحادثات قد نصل
الى هدنه اخرى مع اليات مراقبه اكثر تشددا
تساعدنا في تحديد مواطن
الخلل او المخالفه ان حصل ذلك وان التزموا
الاطراف سيكون ذلك بصيص امل جديد لاخواننا
في السودان وهنا اوجه كلامي مره اخرى الى
الاشقاء في السودان كافه ان الدم السوداني
غالي وان لابد ان نعمل جميعا على
معالجه هذه الازمه بالحوار وعيدا عن
السلاح لان السلاح لا يحل شيء ولن يفضي
الى نتيجه سواء مزيد من الدمار ومسيد من
الابرياء يسقطون
جهود وقف اطلاق النار السعوديه الامريكيه
تاتي مع جهود اخرى امميه بقياده المبعوث
الاممي
قبل ايام مدد له مجلس الامن الدولي المهمه
السياسيه لمده سته اشهر لكن هناك في
السودان من يعتبره سبب الحرب جبهته الجيش
السوداني الخارجيه السودانيه وصفت بالشخص
غير المرغوبه فيه لماذا الاجابه في رساله
وجهها البرهان الى الامم المتحده في اواخر
مايو الماضي اتهم البرهان حينها بالمساهمه
بسلوكه المنحاز واسلوبه المضلل في اندلاع
النزاع وباصراره على فرضه الاتفاق
الايطالي بوسائل واساليب غير امينه كل هذا
بحسب الرساله
[موسيقى]
في السودان جنرالان يتقاتلان وكل
السودانيين والقطاعات تتاثر الحرب واجهزت
على ما تبقى من الاقتصاد السوداني وحتى
الزراعه مصدر قوه السودان تحولت الى نقمه
الارض الخصبه التي تتمتع بالدفء والانهار
باتت عاجزه عن توفير غذاء الشعب السوداني
كان هذا قبل النزاع اما الان فالوضع ازداد
سوءا مزارع السودان البعيده مئات
الكيلومترات عن الخرطوم تعاني مما تشهده
الشوارعها من القتال
[موسيقى]
المناطق الزراعيه في ولايه القضارف كانت
الاكثر تاثرا وبسببها بات شبح الجوع يخيم
على نصف الشعب السوداني بحسب الامم
المتحده في الواقع حقول الجزيره ايضا
تعاني من تداعيات الحرب هي اقرب الى
الخرطوم لكنها تتمتع بميزه قربها من
الانهار وقد تصمد اطول قليلا لكن الامر
مختلف بالنسبه للجارف موسم الامطار حل منذ
ايام ولم يعد هناك مجال لتدارك الوضع فمن
لم يزرع حتى الان لن يحصد شيئا وعلى عكس
مشروع الجزيره اراضي الجضارف يستغلها
افراد وقبائل لكنها تعتمد على الدوله في
التمويل والحصول على البذور اما العمال
فهم في العاده عمال موسميون قادمون من
ولايه اخرى للعمل في المزارع وبحكم الواقع
هم اول متضررين
[موسيقى]
ورغم امتلاكي ولايه القضارف لتربه سوداء
خصبه بسبب قربها من اثيوبيا فهي تستفيد من
الامطار الموسميه الا ان قسوه فصل الجفاف
جعلت السكان لا يستقرون فيها والسبب شح
المياه اذ يصلون نصيب الفرد الواحد من
المياه العذبه تسعه لترات يوميا فقط وهو
اقل بالنصف من المعدل الموصى به من قبل
منظمه الصحه العالميه سبب اخر لازمه
الزراعه غلق البنوك في الخرطوم بسبب
النظام المالي المركزي لم يحصل المزارعون
السودانيون على التمويل وحتى ان وصل الان
فقد فات الاوان الفصول الزراعيه لا تنتظر
عدم حصول المزارعين على التمويل جعلهم غير
قادرين على شراء البذور والاسمده
والمبيدات في الوقت المحدد وبالتالي
40% من احتياجات الحبوب في البلاد مهدده
الازمه الزراعيه امتدت لتضرب قطاع الدواجن
المره ليس بسبب البنوك المغلقه بل بسبب ان
اغلب مزارع تربيه الدواجن تقع في محيط
الخرطوم وبالتالي تضررت سلاسل امدادها
في حكم المؤكد ان الموسم الزراعي القادمه
في السودان سيتاثر بصوره بالغه في ظل توقف
النظام المصرفي والشلل الوزارات والمؤسسات
الحكوميه ذات الصله بالقطاع الزراعي وعدم
قدرتها على الحركه والتنسيق لتوفير
الاحتياجات فضلا عن نقص العماله وصعوبه
حركتها في ظل تعقد الاوضاع الامنيه
واستمرار الحرب الدائره حاليا بالبلاد
وبحسب معلومات العربيه فان ولايه الخرطوم
والمعروفه بانتاجها البستاني الوفير حازت
النصيب الاكبر من التاثر والضرر فالحدائق
البستانيه فيها والبيوت المحميه تعرضت
غالبيتها للعطش نتيجه انقطاع خدمه المياه
وتذبذب التيار الكهربائي فضلا عن الضرر
بمزارع انتاج الاعلاف والدواجن ويبدو ان
اقليمي دارفور وكوردفان ستواجه الزراعه
المطريه فيه مصاعب جمه نتيجه التوترات
الامنيه واذ لا توفر لاحصائيات رسميه توضح
حجم الضرر في الزراعيه في السودان لهذا
الموسم يتضح ان بعضا من عوامل نجاحه باتت
مفقوده
اما الذي جعل المزارعين يعتمدون اعتمادا
كليا على البنوك من اجل زراعه حقولهم السر
في احداث العام الماضي بينما كان العالم
يعاني من ازمه غذاء بسبب حرب اوكرانيا ادت
الارتفاع الاسعار في الاسواق العالميه
لمستويات قياسيه كان السودان يعاني من
كساد المنتجات الزراعيه وسنعود الى
القضارف كمثال اضطر المزارعون لبيع
منتجاتهم بالخساره سمسم مثلا لم تغطي
اسعاره في السوق الى 60% من تكلفه الانتاج
اما بخصوص التمور فقط كان الوضع كارثيا
اسعار البيع لم تغطي حتى تكلفه الجنين
ولهذا ترك التمر في النخيل حتى فساده وهنا
لعبت البنوك دورا سلبيا اخر بسبب مشاكل
التسويق باتت البنوك ترفض تمويل مزارع
سمسم والتمور وحتى المستوردين في الجضارف
ايضا اصبح امام التاجر عشره مشترين
للمنتجات الزراعيه بدلا من مئه في عام
[موسيقى]
حرب المياه بين ايران وافغانستان اشتعلت
اخيرا هي ليست جديده والنزاع مستمرا عليها
منذ عقود المنطقه الواقعه جنوب الحدود
الافغانيه الايرانيه هي من اكثر المناطق
القاحله والفقيره في البلدين يعتمد سكانها
اعتمادا كبيرا على مياه نهرها المنت رغم
انها موطن لعشره انهار مختلفه الا ان
الجغرافيا في افغانستان تتسبب في تدفق
معظم مياه انهارها الرئيسيه الى جيرانها
ما يؤثر على استفاده الافغان بمياه
الصادره من داخل حدودها ويتسبب في صراع
على المياه مع دول الجوار والاسيه ما
ايران نهر هل من نقطه الخلاف بين البلدين
ينبع من جبال هندوكش شمال شرقيه افغانستان
ليمتد على مسافه تتخطى 2150 كيلومترا ويصب
في بحيره هامون جنوب شرقي ايران هامون هي
اراد ارتباط عابره للح على الحدود
الايرانيه الافغانيه وتتكون من ثلاث
بحيرات هامون هلموند وهي بالكامل في ايران
وهمون صباري على الحدود واهمون بوزاك وهي
تقريبا تقع في افغانستان بشكل كامل ترتبط
والب بحيرات الثلاثه بمياه نهرها الموند
وتتغذى عليه كما ان حوض سيستان الذي يوفر
المياه لولايتي سيستان وبلوشستان في ايران
يعتمد على الفيضانات الدائمه لملء بحيراته
الثلاثه
[موسيقى]
طهران وعلى لساني وزير خارجيتها اتهمت
كابول باستخدام نهرها الموند كاداه سياسيه
خاصه ان 95% من المياه تتدفق داخل الاراضي
الافغانيه
نظريا صحت فلم تكن طالبا اول مستخدميها في
افغانستان في الماضي اطلق الرئيس الافغاني
السابق اشرف غني سياسه المياه مقابل
اللجوء موضحا في تصريح له انه اذا لم
يساعد احد افغانستان في ملف اللاجئين لن
تتعاون كابل مع جيرانها في ملف المياه
هي معاهده كل الافغاني مع ايران لكن
مشكلتنا لم تكن في المعاهده نفسها بل في
طريقه تطبيقها اما من بعد اليوم فان مفتاح
هيلمنت بيد الافغان وينفدون ما اتفقوا
عليهما ايران اما ما هو اكثر من المتفق
عليه سيكون بالتفاوض اعطونا النفط ونعطيكم
الماء او ادفعوا مقابل المياه
تدعيته صراعي نهرها ليست مقتصره على ايران
وافغانستان فقط قد تمتدوا الى قوتين
عالميتين الصين وروسيا بحسب تقرير
النشراته صحيفه ازبيستا الروسيه الصحيفه
الرسميه في تقريرها مواصفات افغانستان
بانها تمثل قنبله موقوته لاسيا الوسطى
المنطقه التي تقع في المثلث المعادي اي
بين روسيا الصين وايران التقرير اعتبر ان
زعزعات استقرار اسيا الوسطى عبر افغانستان
سيخدم مصالح الغرب ويوجه ضربه لكل من
موسكو وبكين الى جانب طهران الامر لا
يتوقف عند هذا الحد ربطت الصحيفه الروسيه
بين كميات الاسلحه
والمعدات العسكريه التي تركها الجيش
الامريكي في افغانستان وبين التوتر الجاري
مع ايران في اشاره لخطه امريكيه طويله
المدى
[موسيقى]
ماذا لو قصفت مسيره امريكيه هدفا صينيا
كان المقصود فقط مراقبته في الساعه بعد
دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد دفع تعدد استخدامات
الذكاء الاصطناعي نحو صعودي نهج جديدا
للحرب يعرف باسم الحرب الذكيه او الحرب
القائمه على الذكاء الاصطناعي شيئا فشيئا
تقلل اسلحه الذكاء الاصطناعي اعتمادها على
العنصر البشري ومع تفوق التقنيه وسرعتها
مقارنه بالانسان قد يغيب العنصر البشري
تماما الخطر هنا هو ان الذكاء الاصطناعي
يخطئ احيانا الرادارات في بعض الاوقات ترى
الطائره صديقه كطائره عدو مثلا فماذا ان
كان قرار الضربه الاولى عائد له ماذا لو
قصفت مسيره امريكيه هدفا صينيا كان
المقصود مراقبته فقط كيف ستطمئن واشنطن
الطرف الاخر بان الحادث كان غير مقصود ولم
يتكرر
واشنطن اجابت بنفسها على السؤال في هذا
الاعلان
[موسيقى]
حتى الاسلحه التي لا تعمل بالكامل بالذكاء
الاصطناعي خطره مثلا في عام 2003 اسقطت اف
18 اسقطت عفوا
ثمانيه عشر هورنت بواسطه
الامريكيه بالطبع النظام الالي للباتريت
اخطا وعرف الهورنيت كطائره معاديه
فاستهدفها المشغلون البشريون حروب الذكاء
الاصطناعي ليست خيالا علميا الامر واقع
حتى وان كانت الانظمه غير كامله كما ذكرنا
وهناك للعلم واحده دائره ولو جزئيا حاليا
حرب اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
قد يستخدم الذكاء الاصطناعي في تجنيد
الارهابيين هيئه مراقبه الارهاب في
بريطانيا تحدثت عن الكيفيه برامج الدردشه
للتقنيه تستطيع اقناع البسطاء والمتعصبين
خاصه من الاطفال والمراهقين والارهاب قد
ينطلق من غرف النوم بحسب وصف صحيفه
[موسيقى]
المسؤول عن تشريعات الارهاب بريطانيا
تحدث عن المخاطر وهي اكثر وضوحا من اي وقت
مضى هذه التكنولوجيا بحاجه الى اعاده
الضبط لتعظيم الاستفاده وتقليل المخاطر
ولان الحديث في بريطانيا يتزايد خلال
الايام الماضيه كان الذكاء الاصطناعي
موضوعا اساسيا في محادثات رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني مع الرئيس الامريكي بايدن خلال
زيارته الاولى لواشنطن اوضح سوناك ان
بايدن يدرك هذه المخاطر والتاكيد جاء في
تصريحات خاصه للعربيه نائب المبعوث
الامريكي الى التحالف الدولي
هذا الموضوع يعني يحتاج
الدراسه ومراقبه
ففعلا يعني نراقب هذا الامر وهناك هناك
هناك حوار بين
الدول تحرف الدوري
والشركات
التواصل الاجتماعي
اذا هناك مخاطر كما ذكرنا نتيجه الذكاء
الاصطناعي لكن ليس كل شيء قاتل سوقوا
التكنولوجيا واحد من الاسواق المستفيده
خسائر كبيره شهدها القطاع خلال العام
الماضي وبدايه العام الحالي لكن ووافقه
موقع تتبع
لتسريح العمال من قطاع التكنولوجيا منذ
بدايه 2022 وجد انه وبعد ان ارتفعت عمليات
التسريح لتبلغ ذروتها في يناير تراجعت
لثلاثه اشهر متتاليه السوق باتت مستقره
لكن لمن الفضل في هذا الادعاش جي بي تي
بعد اطلاقه في نوفمبر الماضي بعد هناك
سباق تسلح من قبل الشركات وفق واشنطن بوست
الكل يريد دخول سوق الذكاء الاصطناعي
وبالتالي هم بحاجه لموظفين
ومبرمجين والدليل انه ومنذ منتصف ابريل
ارتفعت اعلانات الوظائف التي تطلب مبرمجين
بنسبه 30% وبالتالي ارتفعت ايضا
الاستثمارات 12 مليارا ونصف المليار دولار
استثمارات من قبل الشركات الناشئه في مجال
الذكاء الاصطناعي من بدايه هذا العام وحتى
الان مقارنه باربعه مليارات ونصف المليار
دولار فقط تم استثمارها في هذا المجال في
العام الماضي
بعد الازمه التي شهدها قطاع التكنولوجيا
في الاشهر الماضيه والتي تمحورت حول
التسريحات الجماعيه تقليص اعداد الموظفين
من الشركات التكنولوجيه الكبرى بدا القطاع
بتشكيل بيئه اكثر استقرارا للعمل في
الشركات التي استغنت عن موظفيها مثل ميتا
ومايكروسوفت وامازون تسارع الان للحق بركب
الذكاء الاصطناعي وبتاثيره على الارباح
المستقبليه وبالتالي يهابون التخلف في هذا
المجال اليوم وبينما تقوم مايكروسوفت ومتى
باستثمارات في هذا المجال يتحول مزاج
الشركات شركات التكنولوجيا من خفض الوظائف
لهادف لزياده الارباح الى سباق التسلح في
مسعى للفوز في المستقبل ربما يقضي الذكاء
الاصطناعي على ملايين الوظائف ولكن
المنتجات والخدمات التي ستسمح بهذا التحول
غير موجوده بعد ويتعين على الشركات ان
تصممها لذا فهي بحاجه لمتمرسين في مجال
التكنولوجيا
وائل المزيد ينضم الينا عبر سكايب عبد
الله السبع المحلل التقني في اندبرند
عربيه اهلا بك سابدا معك من قطاع
التكنولوجيا بعد عام من الخسائر ومن
المزاج السيء في سيليكون فالي ياتي هذا
يعني التطور نتحدث عن طفره هائلات تشهدها
صناعه التكنولوجيا لماذا وكيف الان
اول شيء يعطيكم العافيه قبل ما نبدا هذا
اللقاء لازم نعرف معلومه كم القيمه
السوقيه المتوقعه للذكاء الاصطناعي خلال
السنوات القادمه انا اتوقع رقم عمركم ما
سمعتوه اللي هو
13.5 كوادرليون دولار رقم جدا مهول ما هو
مليون ما هو مليار انما مليون مليار متوقع
انه يكون هذا الرقم اللي هو
13,5 لذلك كل الشركات التقنيه في البترول
حاليا قاعد تحاول تستثمر بشكل جدا كبير في
هذا المجال حتى تعرف كيف تقدر تستفيد منها
وتعظم قيمتها السوقيه فيسبوك واجهه خسائر
خلال سنوات الماضيه تويتر واجهه خسائر
اغلب شركات ثانيه قاعد تواجه خسائر جدا
كبيره لكن متوقع ان الذكاء الاصطناعي راح
يعوض كل الخسائر بالقيمه السوقيه المتوقعه
حقه لذلك كل الشركات حاليا قاعد تضخ فلوس
جدا كثيره في هذا المجال
مرات هائله في وقت تاتي التحذيرات من هذا
التطور الذي يشهده قطاع الذكاء الاصطناعي
خاصه بعد تشاد جي بي تي في ظل هذه
التحذيرات وهذه الاستثمارات اين سنكون نحن
لازم نشوف انا اعرف ان في ناس متخوفه ان
الذكاء الاصطناعي راح ياخذ وظائف الذكاء
الاصطناعي راح يستبدلهم غيرهم لكن خل
نعطيك معلومه قدره الذكاء الاصطناعي على
كشف علاج للسرطان على كشف مرض على كشف
علاج للزهايمر اكبر من قدرته على اخذ
وظيفه خاصه فيه صحيح احنا راح يلغي وظائف
موجوده على على ارض الواقع وهذه سنه
الحياه اول ما دخل الانترنت الغى وظائف
مختلفه لكن اوجد وظائف بديله مثل الامن
السيبراني مثل التسويق من خلال شبكات
التواصل الاجتماعيه او تسويق الكتروني حسب
ما نسميه لذلك وجود الذكاء الاصطناعي يعني
وجود وظائف جديده في دراسه تقول اكثر من
40% من اطفالنا اليوم راح يعملون بوظائف
جديده احنا ما نعرفها وهذا طبيعي بسبب
دخول الذكاء الاصطناعي في حياتنا لذلك قد
نكون متخوف فيه من الذكاء الاصطناعي
والانسان طبيعي يخاف من اي شيء جديد في
حياته لكن قدره الذكاء الاصطناعي وعيد
اكررها على اكتشاف علاج لمرض احنا ما نعرف
علاجه اكبر من قدرته على استبدال وظيفه هي
موجوده راح يستبدل وظائف اي لكن راح يوجد
وظائف اكثر من وظائف اللي هو راح يستبدلها
نعم كما تحدثناها وليس يعني ليس كل شيء
قاتم كما قلنا قبلك قليل ولكن يعني
التحذيرات من الارهاب واستقطاب وتجنيد
الارهابيين كما كان في مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي اول ما ظهرت الان يتعاظم مع
تطور الذكاء الاصطناعي كيف ستتمكن السلطات
من ضبط هذا التطور مع عمليه التجنيد
المتسارعه
طيب كل الشركات حاليا في هذا المجال قاعد
تحاول ان توجد صيغه للحجم من قدرات الذكاء
الاصطناعي السيئه على الانسان لذلك متوقع
انه يكون في وثيقه اتوقع عليها الدول
والشركات للحد من قدرات الذكاء الاصطناعي
اللي ممكن تكون ضاره للانسان زي الوثائق
اللي كل الدول حاليا موقعه عليها لذلك
الذكاء الاصطناعي قادم الذكاء الاصطناعي
يجب الان على الدول انها تتعاون فيما
بينها حتى تحد من قدراته السيئه زي الان
القدرات النوويه اللي موجوده كل الدول
حاليا موقعه انه تقدر تستخدم القدرات
النوويه في استخدام مدني تقدر تستخدم
شكرا جزيلا هو اتحدى كبير وضحت الصوره هو
تحدي كبير بكل الاحوال كنت معنا عبد الله
السبع المحلل المحرر التقني في انديبند
عربيه
ومعك نكون قد وصلنا الى نهايه موضوعاتنا
لليوم وتتابعون غدا في الساعه 60 كوسوفو
قنبله
موقوته قد تشعل حربا في البلقان ليبيا
اتفاقه
الشيطان في التفاصيل وفي التطبيق
في نهايه الساعه ابرزوا احداث الساعه بصور
من الان وحتى الساعه المقبله انا حنين
الشولي وهذه الساعه 60
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات